now that it's spring dr q of star
nursery says it's okay to start planting
our new gardens but how can we tell
which plants in the yard from last year
survived the long cold winter and what
if we want to move some of those plants
around well dr q has the important tips
and tricks
some flowers known as perennials can
usually but not always survive our
desert winters then spring back to life
when the weather warms up how can you
tell when they're dead because we
thought ours died well when they die all
the way back
they will actually have no green
whatsoever down down below but as long
as they have green at the lower parts of
the stems
and you can actually
scratch the stems and get green on them
inside
they
they should sprout back out with new
leaves and dr q at star nursery says the
scratch test works for just about
everything in your yard never assume a
brown plant has kicked the bucket all of
these little bumps here are all latent
buds
that are going to leaf back out i see
okay and so they'll come back out so
you've got to do that test where you
scratch it and see if it's yeah or you
can or you can or you can wait until all
these buds pop out
and then anything that doesn't pop out
just cut off got it a plant's leaves may
be crispy and lifeless but deep inside
the branches and stems the plant's green
cambium layer may still be alive and
well that's what carries all of the
water and nutrients
up and down the stems from the roots up
to the leaves
so the leaves can photosynthesize
giving them their nice green color and
filling the plant with food to keep it
growing and if you feel like relocating
plants around the yard it's a good time
for me to switch because i don't want to
put my plants in shock okay when's it
when's a good time to do that the best
time is to
do it in the early spring or the early
fall
oh
that's when the temperatures are more
mild okay and it's easier on the plants
they don't doesn't stress them as much i
see and the fact that when you dig
plants out of the ground
you're cutting off some of their root
system the milder days give the roots a
chance to grow back and adapt to their
new surroundings so plants can produce
their best bloom and sure enough just
like people they can stress when the
heat does show up like tomatoes they
don't look they don't really set fruit
when the temperatures are over 95
degrees so if you can cover them with a
shade cloth
to protect them and reduce that
temperature once it starts getting
warmer you can elongate their fruiting
period time
so much to know in so little time well
if your yard or garden needs special
attention dr q does make house calls you
can't really dig up everything in the
yard bring it to the nursery to find him
just go to star nursery their website to
arrange a house call and we'll have that
link on our website eightnewsnow.com